oh well I'm Nicholas Kristof from the
New York Times and sweaty from Mumbai
asked what is the one thing you'd like
to see happen in 2012 I guess my answer
would be this is the year of the dragon
and the Chinese calendar Nigel I and
there will be a transition in this fall
to a new leadership community by xi
jinping I'd like to see that begin to
moderate the crackdown that we've seen
in China in recent years to ease the
crackdown you were seeing in Tibet
getting the firing on vens in recent
days and the release from prison of the
great Nobel Peace Prize winning writer
and activist Leo she agua China is going
to definitely be moderating at some
point of the coming years my hope is
that happen in the year of the dragon